Avengers infinity war is so close it's
right around the corner with just barely
over a month away there's obviously a
lot of hype around er right now
especially with interviews by Kevin
Feige and Robert Downey jr. himself and
these photos that we keep getting last
week from Entertainment Weekly a few
days ago from the Empire magazine it's
just really exciting right now so with
all this hype and news that's been going
out the question that's been circulating
around is will some Avengers die and if
so who are the ones that will die from
here on out we're going to be talking
about some speculations and theories
that could contain some major spoilers
for Avengers infinity war so here's your
official warning also before we get
started please be sure to subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date on
everything infinity war if you're still
with me and haven't heard the news yet
I'm sorry to burst your bubble but yes
some Avengers will die in infinity war
when Marvel President Kevin Feige was
asking an interview if characters die in
the movie will it be for real this time
meaning they won't be brought back to
life somehow he replied and I quote yes
I mean I could always list off
characters that we've killed in our
movies that haven't come back but the
big ones which I know they're looking at
I would just say yes people need to be
careful what they wish for end quote
also in an interview by the Toronto Sun
screenwriter Christopher Markus teases
them saying I know nothing about deaths
but if there's a good reason for it they
were open to anything we didn't want to
cut off a flower just as it's beginning
to bloom but a nice big flower
maybe co-writer Stephen McFeely also
said Marvel allowed us big swings so
there wasn't a mandate that everything
had to get tied up in a neat bow so that
they could continue with another one and
another one these movies are the most
successful when the characters undergo
big changes and in certain cases when
some are escorted off the stage with
these interviews and many many more
circulating around it is clear to us
that some Avengers will meet their end
in infinity war also in the same
interview by the Toronto Sun McFeely
also states that this is Thanos's movie
he is the main character of infinity war
they are making Thanos out to be the
biggest baddest villain the MCU has ever
seen and if you're looking to the comics
asking well in the comics who to stano's
kill the answer is everyone they're
going to show how powerful fan
is he's going to be killing off planets
going to be destroying cities and yes he
will be killing some of our favorite
Marvel characters so which characters
are safe and which are at risk well it's
safe to say that spider-man ant-man
Doctor Strange Black Widow guardians of
the galaxy black panther and his crew
and Thor are all safe considering that
they have solo movies in the works right
now you can pretty much consider Bucky
and Falcon safe as well considering that
both characters in the comics at one
point take on the role of Captain
America and the post-credits scene of
black panther we see that Bucky has
taken on the title white wolf so it's
safe to say that he's taking on the new
character from the comics white wolf
that would leave the mantle of Captain
America open to Falcon if they went that
way characters that are up in the air
right now meaning we don't really know
if they're going to die or not
our Scarlet Witch the Hulk war machine
and vision visions kind of an
interesting character in infinity war
because we know that Thanos will need
the mine stone which is in his forehead
and which brought him to life in order
to complete his Infinity Gauntlet but
then we have a scene in one of the
trailers where he's human douchery and
Scarlet Witch used some sort of
technology and magic combination to help
him survive without the Infinity stone
or is this just a hopeful dream by
vision or Scarlet Witch and he actually
dies in the movie I guess we'll have to
wait till it comes out to find out then
we have the characters who are most
likely to die the first being Hawkeye
for starters he's not really in any of
the trailers that we have in fact I
think you only see his back in one of
the trailers then there's the fact that
he actually has a full family he has a
wife and he has kids what better way to
demonstrate vanos his power and his
ruthlessness than to kill off Hawkeye
this will also unite the Avengers given
the fact that he did have a wife and
kids and he's also completely human and
has no powers
Thanos can probably look at him and kill
him and then you have Captain America
and Iron Man going back to what
Christopher Markus teased about in the
Toronto Sun interview stating we didn't
want to cut off a flower just as it's
beginning to bloom but a nice big flower
maybe well Captain America and Iron Man
are the two big flowers there's the two
leaders of the Avengers and again what
better way to demonstrate than OSes
power than by killing them all so both
actors Chris Evans and Robert
jr. cost the studio the most money and
neither actor has renewed their contract
to play the characters so does this
really mean that some of our favorite
characters are going to die and not be
brought back in Avengers infinity war
I'll leave you with this quote by Robert
Downey jr. and the Toronto Sun interview
I mentioned earlier there's been a
quantum shift in the way that things are
going now where all these different
franchises are on the horizon and
they're bringing new energy and some of
us are maybe tapping out are going away
for who knows how long in the future
what do you think will happen in
Avengers infinity war do you think some
Avengers will die and if so who do you
think will die and how let me know in
the comments below and maybe I'll make a
video about some of your ideas don't
forget to drop a like and don't forget
to subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Avengers infinity war Marvel and
all things superhero thank you so much
for watching and have a great day